we're all here because bob
loved us
he loved everyone here that's
that's why we're here because he loved
you
it was a full house at bob saget's
private memorial including a rare
appearance by two of his tv daughters
mary kate and ashley olsen we love each
other and we've been friends all these
years
and we've been there for each other and
people have heard all this ad nauseam
but it's
it's honestly true
this rare footage from inside the cast's
reunion is featured in the new netflix
special dirty daddy the bobsage tribute
we thank you
and honor honor you and bring you glory
because you let us
know his love and we got to love him
back
and we thank you
that's candace cameron beret saying a
prayer standing next to full house
co-stars dave quiere lori laughlin and
john stamos who couldn't help but bring
some light to the moment all in bob's
style of course
dick stories
prayer
that's what happens when you grow up
with bob saget you go one way or the
other
i love you i love you more
up next dave cuiet who got emotional
talking about his longtime friend
man
i
i'm
gonna take a long time in my life to
process this but you know what every
time
that i feel sad
i am so lucky and we're all so lucky
that
we get to fill that well up
with thousands
of
laughs and beautiful stories and love
i share all those memories but together
us
as a family have so many funny amazing
memories that will
carry us through the rest of our lives
the memorial happened back in january
the month bob died now we don't know if
mary kate ashley or laurie made a speech
at the memorial if they did it didn't
make it into the special but no doubt
they all showed their love and support
for the beloved tv dad it's been really
tough it's been really
difficult i think for all of us in in
different ways e.t sat down with some of
bob's full house family including dave
candice andrea barber and scott weinger
just two months after his death and they
shared why being together helps the
grieving process coming together to do
this conference this weekend was
important to us because it was just a
way for us to spend time together
we're excited to meet everyone and meet
the fans but we just we wanted a good
bonding weekend because uh it it helps
through it helps the process through the
degree
the stars also opened up about why they
think his character danny tanner
impacted so many people i think it was
this warmth i think that with all of his
humor and his famously inappropriate
humor
he was really just he had a huge heart
and um and it everybody could you know
we could you know people who knew him
well felt it but the whole world you
just you know the whole world sensed it
and felt it he was you know it's funny
this whole america's dad he really was
and um
and and he connected all of us he was
always texting all of us and and i would
get mad at him i would say bob you're
always on your phone and now i know why
because he was always texting us and
calling us and checking in and you know
he was always there for all of us he
would always check are you okay you know
um
you know i know gas prices are going up
but are you okay
you know i mean he was
you know he was
really
the connective tissue between all of us
[Music]